Tuesday's presidential debate between
Joe Biden and Donald Trump was a total
dumpster fired
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment that
was really a productive segment wasn't
it
keep yapping man and Hillary Clinton had
one thing on her mind
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this hey let me
just tell you no no no Mr President the
90-minute debate was straight up chaotic
chock full of countless interruptions
endless crosstalk and some seriously Bad
Manners
okay true gentlemen is
I hate to raise my voice but it seems to
be why shouldn't I be different than the
two of you so much so that moderator and
Fox News host Chris Wallace had to
practically beg the president to stop
cutting in I think that the country
would be better served if we allowed
both people to speak with fewer
interruptions I'm appealing to you sir
to do that well and him too well frankly
you've been doing more interruptions
that's all right but he does plenty well
less than sir less than plenty no less
than you have naturally Joe was
frustrated AF and it all came to a head
with this we're still left
my second hand discomfort is Raging
anyway that's when one Twitter user
wrote quote will you shut up man is the
line of the night I so feel for Hillary
right now because I'm positive she
wanted to say that and couldn't well
Hill saw that tweet and responded simply
you have no idea
um who else is dead because I'm fully
deceased after that but it gets even
better when another Twitter user asked
quote has anyone checked in on Hillary
Clinton girl I'm so sorry she replied
quote thanks I'm fine but everyone
better vote of course Hillary went three
rounds with then fellow candidate Trump
back in 2016 when she was the Democrat
running against him it was during the
third debate that Trump notoriously
referred to her as a nasty woman is to
replenish such a nasty trust fund but
Hillary wasn't the only celeb to weigh
in on the debate Joy Behar tweeted quote
and they say the view suffers from
crosstalk please adding Biden just told
the liar to shut up this is getting good
Deborah Messing also addressed that
heated moment tweeting that Joe Biden
was speaking for all of us meanwhile
Kerry Washington called the whole thing
horrifying and man what what the hell
was that the base it was that a debate
what did we I'm I am so what was that
I'm so I am so stressed right now I have
a kink if it just it felt like I just
slept on an air mattress late night
hosts also gave their two cents on the
televised event and Jimmy Fallon was
literally all of us seriously did anyone
take anything away from tonight was that
helpful to any American
the only person who enjoyed that was
Vladimir Putin while he was stroking a
cat yes yes yes
[Laughter]
honestly sitting through that debate
felt like getting a covet test in both
nostrils at once Stephen Colbert echoed
all that and addressed all that
crosstalk forget fact-checking this
debate we couldn't even do any sentence
finding then there was Jimmy Kimmel who
just told it like it is it was a
terrible debate I I call it a nightmare
but at least during a nightmare you get
some sleep
[Music]
foreign